هذه هي المقاطعة التي
تعتبر آخر منطقة آمنة نسبيًا يمكن
للأشخاص الذين يريدون الفرار من النظام
والقصف الروسي أن
يأتوا إليها بالفعل - المشكلة هي أن
الوافدين الجدد منذ شهور كانوا يعيشون في ظروف
كهذه بالكاد قادرين على توتير
اثنين  البطانيات حول أشجار الزيتون من أجل
المأوى ، وذلك
لأن المخيمات الرئيسية الموجودة هنا
ممتلئة تمامًا ، لقد ذهبوا وقد طلبوا
خيامًا قيل لهم إنه لا توجد خيام
وتقدر المنظمات غير الحكومية أن واحدة من كل
ثلاث نساء هنا إما
ترضع.  أو هي حامل
، وُلد هذا الطفل الصغير قبل شهر من اضطرار
والديها إلى الفرار من أمهات أخريات
تحدثنا إليهن لنقول إنهن لا
يملكن حفاضات أنجبت امرأة واحدة تحدثنا إليها
في خيمتها
تحت أشجار الزيتون.
أن يكون
القصف في الجزء الجنوبي من
المقاطعة مكثفًا لدرجة أن الطائرات المقاتلة تحلق في
سماء المنطقة تقريبًا ، وهو
أمر مرعب للغاية على العيادات الطبية.
يتم استهدافهم وهكذا يفر المزيد والمزيد من
الناس إلى منطقة
يتم فيها ضغطهم على
الحدود التركية والعديد
ممن تحدثوا هنا يتساءلون كيف
مرت ثماني سنوات من هذا
الصراع ليس لديهم عالم فقط  القادة
يفشلون في وقف العنف الذي شعروا به حتى
في تزويدهم
بأبسط الأشياء
أروى ديمون CNN في المحافظة سوريا